each 2002 millennium ah Treasury [ __ ] oh
well you [ __ ] up oh [ __ ] you love I'm
gonna start all over you get me nervous
well I'll get you now cuz you're hot FK
you up that out more like this alright
so we're gonna start over so we just
started so it's gonna be easy um well
it's just um that hot you might as well
take off your clothes without my clothes
in the car I'm gonna get your number
before we're done yeah three two three
four nine four all right where'd you
grow up treasure where did I grew up in
South Central LA at 7:35 it's called
Kelly ma come I grandmother passed away
when I was giving her a bell she was 97
years old she passed away at 907 while I
was giving her a bath and how was your
childhood oh it was awesome yeah it was
your parents I had both my parents my
mother and my father good for you
and both of my sisters grandparents what
my mom's my mother's mother stayed on
the right side of Street and my father's
father stayed on the left side uh Street
in a two-story house where I stayed to
this day did having all that family
nearby help you you think huh
they're having all that family oh yeah
he helped me to be a strong black woman
I ain't taking no wooden nickels would
nickels at all and it's all how was your
childhood happy it was awesome for my
12th birthday I got a pony I had a pony
flipped my purse what birthday huh and
when and he finally passed away when I
turned 23 that was my buddy
and his name was buddy and what if did
you leave home
16 16 what kind of kid were you a high
school did you finish high school
oh I finished high school so you looked
at 16 infinite yes because I want to be
all my you know my mom said if you think
you're grown go out and get on your own
and I've been on my own ever since I was
16 now I'll be 52 next month and I still
live in the home that my grandparents
left me and I don't take know me in
there because I'm not married yet and I
made my grandpa a promise if I wasn't
met he passed away in 2000 I told him if
I wasn't married I'm reading them into
my house and you can't go to no hotel we
can you cannot get no [ __ ] understood
yeah and what kind of kid with your high
school well that was great kid I'll race
right
I was a cheerleader so good childhood
yeah I know
awesome cha hula and now you're working
the streets yeah I'm fake yeah what when
did that start
thank when I was like 23 to put I wasn't
out there selling myself just to be sent
on myself I sold myself for my three
sons you have three kids I have three
sons three boys 3432 and 27 can you
raise them and I raise them all with
their dads with their father
good field mm-hmm when once they started
cheated
I kicked them to go to the car your boys
are how old now my oldest son Theodore
he's 34 Pierre is 33 and my baby you
meet he's 27 have you ever been arrested
for doing this huh have you ever been
arrested for doing this no hey oh no
never been caught never I always been
caught you know by selling drugs I think
I told her good why the drug isn't why
the dope is not in evidence did you ever
work as a pimp
hell no I'm a really good I keep my own
[ __ ] money for my son's book a
pimp
cuz pimps get [ __ ] too if the price is
right on [ __ ] I'll get [ __ ] - but
you're a sexy white man don't know why
don't [ __ ] love you like [ __ ] up
well so so you'll work what hours
typically damn what hours will you be
out and figure out at night during the
day changes that we the early morning
shift between 2 & 6 2 & 6 a.m. yeah the
early morning hours um these are these
are men going to work or coming home
from drugs this means going to work or
getting off work truck drivers yeah even
me they work for the gas company the
Department of Water and Power
yeah and these guys are there they are
blue collar man yeah and they're there
all races no white Hispanic black I only
put two races Hispanic or Caucasian
that's it
I don't like that man I mean I got my
ought to do my sundae bar black man but
black man don't know how to treat a
black Queen so I prefer out of my race
ain't been with a black man in 27 years
I don't know what it feels like to pull
a black dick to go up with me I
masturbate my own self but they get
competitive out there on the street
sometimes all the other girl no no not
for you not for me you know your
personality kind of takes over yeah yeah
uh-huh I see that do you feel like all
the years working that doing that for a
living history I never caught I never
and I'll be 52 next month on a third I
never had no STD a little creepy thing
they call the crabs because if your dick
came fit in the Magnum I can't [ __ ] with
you ain't got time to get lockjaw trying
to suck that [ __ ] dick what can't get
up won't get out no I don't do that no
you feel like all the years of doing
this has changed you handle a lot how's
that to get my own money [ __ ] a pimp
[ __ ] and these young girls call these
[ __ ] daddy uh-huh I thought I called
my father father I don't call him daddy
because it takes a hell of a man to be a
father
any news gonna be your daddy it sounds
like you had a good relationship with
your dad I feel doing he showed you four
years old where is a lot of the females
I don't have a father they grew up and
broken hunk I grew up with a mom and
with a mother and a father and it seems
like I got principles in more than by
myself by the Long's if that was giving
me it wasn't enough money so I could be
arena getting in my own money but it
seems like a lot of the other females
are maybe looking for the temp to play
out their dad role they called him to
this daddy ain't calling no [ __ ] day I
call my I call my father father ain't
calling no where the [ __ ] daddy you you
ain't my daddy
my father I call him off him telling my
head so what's the worst thing about
working the street
he's got to be careful and cautious who
you getting a car wait use your
intuition yeah that good feeling
have you had bad things happen dude no I
never been raped stabbed another day
most of the females have done have been
injured all that why do you think you
haven't why do you think you have not
had that happen because I'm a child of
God and I feel like when I want
something wrong when a man in it I like
I look in their cars if you don't have
no door handles something wrong with you
our chief thing windows out and I was
pure about the window
thank thank God I never had that
experience no one's even tried never
they're like I tell them you run around
the streets making for women you don't
know who you knew you [ __ ] wait I
like I tell them I'm a crazy [ __ ] from
the Midwest anything you are me you from
the Midwest no no I tell them oh you
told from south-central yeah yeah that's
him I'm a crazy [ __ ] front of me a with
your own family got life insurance for
you you are here [ __ ] with me trying
to buy some [ __ ] go home and [ __ ] your
wife are you girlfriend or whatever a
female I think they almost needs your
personality I never I never been
gang-raped damn door shut as you can see
my body and I got three sons you know I
talked to a person I talked to them I
don't talk at them something going wrong
in your household that you out here on
figure work looking for healing women
and I'm 52 years old I ain't ashamed my
age like I tell these [ __ ] I'm
like I'm not insecure with myself or my
[ __ ] body
I never been shot stabbed gang rape
another day thanks to the grace of God
and your family knows you're doing this
yeah I know it what about your sons they
don't like it but all well do you think
this is just like an accepted thing in
your in south-central a lot of a lot of
women will do this right a lot a lot of
one we do it for drugs but I do it to
keep myself up and the money that I make
I sent to my three sons in a pen I don't
know what other woman's do but I do it
for a reason
so you're my son your three sons are in
the pen for what oh my uh robbery home
invasion
and robbing the [ __ ] they got
all the way she did like you from name
on I ain't taking none less do you work
on the neighborhood's other than Figaro
hmm do you work on their neighborhoods
they call me I'm a car world they just
called me because I really don't stand
on the street north
oh it's called me see you work to do my
phone yeah got it but I don't prefer
black man so I'm put on the comp [ __ ]
black [ __ ] black man don't know how to
treat a black African Queen I know what
it's like to have things
how do Hispanic or Caucasian men treat
you differently like a lady they open
the door for you they put them we go out
to eat they put a little cuff over your
left they took a chair out for me and
all that nigga's gonna do that and I got
a pet peeve if your nails dirty you take
if your nails and your total is dirty
the first thing meet the shower is your
feet in your hands how you gonna try to
holler at me and your nails in you and
your feet is dirty in a statement and
then and you're saying and you got [ __ ]
stains all up your [ __ ] drugs
you didn't even walk your ass today I
don't do it
I prefer Caucasian or Spanish all right
I already mean how much money will you
make it a night - jeez
really hey oh yeah that's good money I
ain't sitting for nothing less cuz I got
three sons I gotta see him money - in
the pan they called me on the phone but
I like you mark know you got some
beautiful eyes you got some long days
you just pick me up and [ __ ] me ah ah ah
you want me around - just [ __ ] me I wrap
my legs around you like what I just [ __ ]
you all day long all right I'll get your
phone number for we're done yeah they do
three all right you're fun well treasure
thank you so much for talking to me
ah keep laying on that for ten something
camera off let me show you what I'm
gonna do you got a bathroom in here I do
I got a TV oh yeah can you turn this out
yeah
you